Sarah Silverman
[Applause]
oh great
look at you playing Vegas the MGM grams
so proud I'm not taking a jet there
tonight but uh but I'm very proud of you
come on
we boat we worked hard and we played by
the rules you taught me how to exfoliate
with the dry brush before my shower good
I mean it was like we're on the bet it
was you you bullied me into around a
basketball court you look you don't
exfoliate with the dry brush before you
shower I didn't even know that's what to
do this is the honk you plan to come out
here with no ad with the drug none at
all I don't know I just I saw you and I
remembered it cuz I think of you every
time I do it let's talk politics you're
very brave to meet you that's right
isn't she perfect yeah so um you're for
Trump right all right
sound 100 Trump is the the product of a
long tradition of pointing at other
people and accusing them of doing what
you're doing and that's you know here uh
you're a bit did you know you know that
ever since lucky Oh what the pundit
no it's a good thing but ever since you
were at the the Democratic convention
and you pointed at the Bernie people and
said you're being ridiculous and I
thought it was wonderful and told us to
stretch but what is that idea where the
crown heavily now that you've been
anointed as a someone who's gonna lead
us in our political thinking yeah of
course yeah no I don't know I mean I
there's no one more Bernie than me I'm
inspired every day by Bernie Sanders the
good news is you know people who change
the world are almost never the president
you know so we don't have them for four
years we have them forever is that so
bad to settle for well actually a people
[Applause]
that the president is someone who
changes the world yes please
we remember in throughout history that
have changed our world are almost never
the president that's completely not true
as I'm the very the very reason we're so
afraid of Trump is because that it is
true that the boy see your line of
thinking but I'm thinking about it it's
not one thing you know some of those
people changed the world but Martin
Luther King didn't send troops into the
south to make sure that the black people
could go to college are you sure
President Kennedy did that because of
president sure because this pressures
from outside video options British gate
needs an ally in office that's right
that's why I don't understand these
Bernie or bust people you know I don't
know what their long game is I don't
know what their perfect dream scenario
is i berners-lee I'm asking or am I
being obtuse no you are but it seems
that it would be good to up now are not
I want to talk to them cuz yeah what are
you 28 29 now you're all mouth yeah
I [ __ ] hate that that's a big funny
joke you're a millennial and one with
stamina now let me read that the polls
here on Clinton 18 to 34 people Clinton
31% uh-huh Trump 26 Gary Johnson 29%
Gary Johnson Gary Johnson Gary John
listen is a [ __ ] idiot I like him
he's a nice guy but he's another in my
basket of [ __ ] idiots a nice
I voted and I believe you did in 2004
Ralph Nader yes but this is not yes
idiot right yeah and he wasn't an idiot
but he also wasn't gonna win and it was
a mistake vote our content I admitted it
was a mistake okay
but Gary Johnson can I show you a little
we put a little montage of Gary together
just to remind and we thought thought he
was a cool guy you know he smokes pot he
was in the pot he's not making pot look
good pastas and making good right pot is
cool hot is cool it doesn't make you
know what's also cool reading yeah
here's a little bit of Gary Johnson for
those thinking of voting for him aleppo
and what is Aleppo Aleppo
not knowing that there's a city in
between the be the two forces who's your
favorite part later
who's my favorite any anybody pick any
leader hunk I'm having a brain I'm on a
mini box I think I could sign up that
for the whole today oh we're really and
by the way for the people 29% 18 to 34
who I assume a lot of them were Bernie
people right
okay here's some minimum-wage Hillary's
with Bernie not Gary Johnson believes in
no minimum wage TPP he's for that
Hillary and Bernie are against it
citizens united all the money you want
in politic gun control wants none of
that financial regulation universal
health care Eastern rupees for repealing
Obamacare free college he's against that
he's for nothing that you [ __ ] people
what it's not even like is that you no
one's even miss informing them about him
like they are would like with your
friend you know it's like people yeah no
that's true what you were saying was
exactly right people vote because
they're totally misinformed and that is
a real thing